when you think that your twins in a
pickup a metal chair and start swinging
at you she's going to congrats queen bee
Johnse you are the Madonna of our time a
queen bee you're gonna be a mom of twins
I queen bee Congrats on your double
bundle of Yahweh our mom always said
that two was like having four so
congrats now you have five you are going
to be a fantastic mother and amazing
mother to twins so you're gonna slay
that game just like you slay every game
we are Loki hoping for Gemini babies
we're Gemini twins so cross fingers we
want to give you our wonder twin power
here's a little advice from this twin
duo to your twin below even though you
might get them the same things and dress
them alike they're individuals so it's
important to treat them as such
hopefully no matching names right no
Megan and Reagan no Brian and Brian no
the Shona LaShawn and don't confuse
their names when you're dealing with
twins they're a package one of them gets
in trouble guess what the other ones in
trouble too Beyonce feel free to dress
them alike but always make sure it's
gonna be the same color same exact thing
Jaime's acting otherwise the other twin
will always think that their twin has
the better thing no matter what it is
there will be times when you do not
understand what your twins are saying we
speak our own language twin speak it's
real be prepared for it there's like a
whole like vocabulary just between us
yes son don't take sides you'll never
win because then they'll team up against
you we'll be ready by the time we were
you know seven eight
etc we really started developing our own
unique style definitely when it's a
dress in separate outfit you never can
go wrong with a BOGO when you have a
twin you're born with the best friend
I mean BFF right here chances are when
you're talking with someone
your twin is also talking to them you
can get the disk from your twin as you
are getting older and you're going out
and you're hitting the club you can
bring them a lot you know and they're
going to be helping you out many
proposals for threesomes but I would say
be selective you know don't go with the
first one that you're offered sometimes
I do connect with girls better having a
twin sister if you're Esso does not like
your twin forget it to go what about now
Drake lied when he said if I had a twin
I would still choose you make sure your
sister is not looking better than you
when you're inside of your boyfriend a
few of his like really good friends and
does it become of my boyfriend it was
convenient
yes twins are going to get a lot of
people who are constantly going to
compare you oh who has the bigger eyes
let this installer who bigger smaller
who's smarter right don't get so caught
up on the small things and really
understand and appreciate like the
differences that you guys have your
different people your unique individuals
and you should embrace that
and then the fact that you're twins like
this is a special bond this isn't
something that happens every day and
it's pretty incredible all the
scratching and the hair pulling and the
metal chairs that we've thrown at each
other we're both still alive
we've survived it all you have someone
that will always be your number one fan
will always laugh at your jokes it works
it's a dynamic duo and together
twins can conquer the world
[Music]